[SLEIGH BELLS]
ANKUR KOTWAL: Welcome to a
Google Developers Live Session
on the Santa Tracker
for Android app.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: My name
is Jan-Felix Schmakeit, and
I'm a developer programs
engineer on the Android team.
I'm based here in Sydney, and I
worked on the Santa Tracker
Android app.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Hi, I'm Ankur
Kotwal, and I'm a developer
advocate on the Android team.
I'm also based out of Sydney,
Australia, and was also an
engineer on the Santa
Tracker Android app.
So what's Santa Tracker
Android?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: That's
a really good question.
So Santa Tracker, in general,
the idea was that you can
follow Santa on Christmas,
even you can
see where Santa is.
And because we're both on the
Android team, we thought it
would be really nice if you have
something native on your
phone, and that's where
Santa Tracker Android
application came in.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah, so I mean
from our point of view, the
vision was that we would focus
on an amazing map experience
where you can follow Santa on
Christmas Eve as he traveled
the world and delivered
presents.
Let's talk a little bit
the technology then.
What is it that we used
to put Santa Tracker
together this year?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: As you've
seen, we've released the
Google Maps API version 2 for
Android, and that allowed us
to put together a fantastic
map experience with 3D
buildings, and you can
tilt the cameras
and zoom the camera.
So all sorts of really
cool stuff.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah, and the
great thing is is that it's we
were able to build
an experience.
It's interactive but also
passive, and that's what we're
going to talk about
in this session.
How we built it and what was
our vision behind it.
So we've already said that the
experience is going to be
Santa moving from location
to location on a map.
So pop quiz.
With this new library, what do
we use to drop our map in onto
the screen?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: So we're
using a map fragment.
And that's just like any other
fragment you've used on
Android before, but
it's a Google Map.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Neat.
So people have been asking for
a map fragment for a while.
We can now have multiple map
fragments if you want, but
we're only obviously using
the one, right?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
Yeah, just one.
ANKUR KOTWAL: OK, so now we
have a map, and we want to
drop Santa in on the screen.
How do we drop Santa in?
How do we display Santa
on that map?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: So Santa
is actually just another
marker on the map.
So we have a special icon, so
when you create a marker you
can set a target to the
location, and you
can also set an icon.
In this case, we have a
little special icon
we're using for Santa.
That way, you can see where
Santa is at the moment.
ANKUR KOTWAL: OK, so
Santa is there.
We have the map.
You said we could
set a location.
Santa is going to move.
So how do we do the
animation then?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Yeah,
that's a good question.
So basically, we're changing
the position of the marker
along the way.
So we have a thread running, and
we're basically saying OK,
move the marker, update
the location of
that particular marker.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Interesting.
So how do we know where Santa
is at any point in time?
Because, I mean obviously, we're
communicating with Santa
as he travels on Christmas Eve
so that he tells us that hey,
I've reached this location.
I'm on my way here.
How is that all working?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: So
basically the back-end is
based-- so we have an API, a
Santa API as we've called it
internally, because we have a
few different clients that
actually talk to Santa.
So instead of Santa having to
talk to every single person
around the world, Santa is just
talking to our engineers,
and then all the clients can
access this particular API.
And the API was actually
built in App Engine.
ANKUR KOTWAL: He's in Go.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: And the
Android app is accessing it.
We have a Chrome extension, and
we have a website as well.
And they're all accessing the
same API that we're using to
find out where Santa is and
where he's heading next.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So that App Engine
API basically notifies
all the clients that here is
Santa's latest up-to-date
location on the night.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
That's right.
ANKUR KOTWAL: OK, great.
So as Santa travels from place
to place, location to
location, I guess, how do we
tick off a location as having
been visited?
What are we doing on the Android
app to show that?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: So we have
markers that show where
Santa has already
been on the map.
So every location Santa has
visited, as we know from the
time stamp and from what Santa's
told us, we basically
put a marker and say, look,
Santa has already been there.
And you can go off, and you can
click on and it shows you
how many presents Santa's
delivered there.
So we actually add a marker
for each place Santa has
visited along the way.
ANKUR KOTWAL: OK, great.
Is there any tricks that
you had to go across?
I mean you're telling if
you're adding markers.
We're going to have lots and
lots of markers on this map.
And if I zoomed out, we--
are there performance
considerations?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Yeah, so
as you can imagine, Santa is
visiting a lot of places
around the world.
And the map view actually is
very performant, even if we
have a couple [INAUDIBLE]
markers on the map
at the same time.
That's actually really fantastic
to see even on
low-end devices.
One issue, though, is if you
have a lot of markers and
you've zoomed out, for
example, they tend
to overlap a bit.
So there were a few tricks we
had to use to make sure that
our Santa marker, which is just
another marker, always
stays on top.
So when you tilt the camera, for
example, that's where the
zed index issue comes in.
So which marker's on top.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Which marker
is in front is
what you mean, right?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Exactly.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Because,
obviously, I can imagine on a
map, if I'm looking at a map in
a certain way and I've got
a bunch of markers, the ones
that are closest to me should
be the ones in front.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Exactly
right, yeah.
ANKUR KOTWAL: And that would
make sense for the location
marker, but when it comes to
Santa, we kind of want to show
Santa on top or in front
of all the markers.
So I can see that that's
interesting.
It looks like we're using the
library in ways they hadn't
really designed for.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Yeah,
that's true, that's true.
Yeah.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So you mentioned
also before that we had a
thread running that updated
Santa's location.
We also seemed to be
talking to an API.
So there's obviously some
background work, some user
interface work.
How did you pull all of
that stuff together?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: So the one
issue here is that you can
only interact with the
map on the UI thread.
So we had to make use of
different threads.
You should never access an API
or a web service on the UI
thread, for example.
ANKUR KOTWAL: I think what you
mean is you shouldn't do any
networking on the foreground
of the UR thread.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Exactly.
The same goes for calculations,
because we're
doing a lot with latitudes and
longitudes, and a lot of other
calculations.
So we didn't want to do any
of that in the UI thread.
But the issue was you could
only access the
map on the UI thread.
So there a few things we
had to think about.
We had to be very careful
on how you design your
application, how you
interact with it.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Right, so we
obviously did some pretty
hardcore thread synchronization
there to make
sure that everything runs
smooth and will
run smooth on the--
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Having
said that, [INAUDIBLE]
fantastic for us, and actually
worked quite well.
Very easy to use.
ANKUR KOTWAL: There you go.
Good tip there.
Now the other thing I guess I
want to ask you is in terms of
the Android life cycle, because
if you think about
Android, we have on create, on
start, on resume, on pause.
We have a couple of
hundred markers or
thousands of markers.
Do we need to do anything
special because Santa's moving
all the time as well?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Yeah, the
thing is Santa doesn't stop.
So when you pause the
application and you
go back into it.
The question was how do we
restore the correct state?
So how do we tick off
the right places
Santa has been to?
In our case, we found it was
the easiest if we reset the
map completely and add
everything back in so we know
exactly what Santa's up to.
We can put Santa in exactly
the right spot.
And performance-wise, it wasn't
actually an issue at all.
If you make sure you've
calculated as much as you can
beforehand, your storing all
the data in the correct
format, so we're using a secret
live database in the
background.
It actually works really well.
ANKUR KOTWAL: OK.
So at this stage, Santa's
animating on the map, but it's
really hard to tell where he's
been and where he's going.
So what solutions did
we have for that?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Yeah, so
we noticed that as we were
experimenting and
using the app.
So we decided to make it really
obvious that Santa is
moving across the map by
showing his progress.
So basically, we've added a line
from where he's left, the
last place where he's been,
and where he is
currently on the map.
So you could zoom out.
You can correctly see where
Santa is at the moment.
ANKUR KOTWAL: I'm sorry.
From a developer standpoint,
how do we draw the line?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Quite
literally, we're using a
polyline line to do that.
So we have two points as
part of a polyline--
where he has been, his departure
place, his departure
location, and his current
location, and we simply have a
thread where we update one
of the points, and that's
basically how we move the
line together with
Santa across the map.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Awesome.
So polylines are obviously
a feature of the map view
API of version 2.
And then what about the
destination itself?
Because you could think that
the source is a marker, the
destination is a marker.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Basically,
we added just
basically another marker.
That a bit transparent.
It's basically to show that this
is where Santa is going
to be, that's where
he's heading.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Gotcha.
So now we had a map, and we had
Santa moving on that map.
Location to location,
the location
markers would show up.
But really one of the things
that we wanted to do was make
sure that users didn't have to
play with the app, didn't have
to pan the app around
to follow Santa.
So what do we do from a passive
experience point of
view to make that fun?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: So we took
advantage of the camera
animation so you can control
the camera in a map view.
That's what we're using here.
So basically, as Santa is moving
around the map, we're
animating the camera as well.
We're zooming in and making sure
that Santa is always on
the screen.
So now we can really
see that the
application is coming together.
We have a map.
We have Santa.
Santa is moving on a map.
But I think there's still
something missing that really
makes this a global experience
that everyone around the world
can enjoy the app.
ANKUR KOTWAL: That's right.
Localization.
We wanted to make sure that this
app was something that
people all over the world could
experience, and people
all over the world speak
different languages.
So we've actually spent quite a
lot of time localizing this
app in as many languages as
possible, and have covered
just about every language
that Android supports.
So all of the strings
are localized.
But the thing to keep in mind,
when you do localization is
not just that the strings
change, you have to worry
about the context, that things
make sense, and also from a
developer's point of view you
actually have to look at
things like your layout, how big
all your different fields
are, because some languages
actually take up more
characters to display the same
level of text than others.
So in some ways, English
is a bit of a
medium in terms of size.
Some of the Asian languages use
finer characters that take
up less space.
But then languages like German
actually have an English
character set, but they actually
have quite a lot of
characters for each
of the words.
So with all of these pieces
coming together in our
development life cycle, this was
really the right time to
send out a version of the app
for internal testing to
Googlers all around the world
to get their feedback.
So we did that.
Did you find any overwhelming
feedback that people were
really feeling strongly about?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Yeah,
so we built this passive
experience where we always
followed Santa, but we found
people wanted to go back to see
where Santa has already
been or where he might
head next.
They wanted to go around and
explore the map themselves.
So that was something we had
to consider in other apps.
ANKUR KOTWAL: And so up until
now, what we'd done was focus
on the passive experience
where the camera would
automatically follow Santa, but
now, people wanted to be
able to move stuff around.
So that was a really strong
piece of feedback.
But one of the pieces--
one of the sort of initial
visions for Android app was
that we didn't want there to be
any user interface on the
app itself.
We didn't want there to be
buttons and things for people
to toggle, because at the end
of the day on a phone you've
got such small amounts of real
estate, and obviously, on a
tablet you have more.
But remember, one of the user
experience guidelines for
Android is that regardless
whether you're on a phone or a
tablet, you should be able
to have the same
functionality, right.
So the layout, even the layouts
can change, but all
the functionality
should be there.
So given that we had this vision
that we didn't want too
much user interface, but users
want to be able to toggle
between an automatic and a
manual mode, what do we do?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
Yeah, so that was a
really interesting question.
So rather than just simply
adding a button, we made this
a bit more interactive.
So basically as soon as you
touch the map, we came out of
Santa cam mode-- that's what we
called it, Santa cam mode,
because you're following
Santa.
So as soon as you touch the map,
a little button popped
up, and you can basically say
oh, hang on, if I want to
follow Santa again, I can
tap on that button.
But we also added a time out
to it, because the passive
experience was really what we
were going for and what the
focus of the app was.
So after 20 seconds, 25 seconds
of inactivity on the
map, we actually popped the
count down up, and you had
five seconds before we enabled
Santa cam again.
You'd follow Santa again.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Cool.
I mean that to me was like
a really fun bit.
And the other point we should
mention that although we
called it the Santa cam button
or the toggle, it
was a styled button.
We didn't just have a normal
rectangular button.
We tried to make it a bit more
fit within the theme of Santa.
So what did it look like?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: So it
didn't actually look like any
normal standard button that
you've seen before.
It was round.
There was a big, big icon of--
Santa icon was on there.
So obviously, it was
interactive.
You can touch it, you
got the feedback.
But it didn't look like
a normal button.
But we actually spent a fair bit
of time making sure that
people knew that they could
interact with it.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yes, including
the touch feedback.
That's very important.
When you're building custom
user interfaces, touch
feedback is very important,
because otherwise it doesn't
look like people can
interact with it.
OK, so now we had this
Santa cam toggle.
You could go in and out of it.
But how would people know
whether they were in Santa cam
or not in Santa cam?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Yes, so we
wanted to add something to
make it obvious that you're
following Santa or you can
interact with the map.
So we actually added a border
around the map.
And all we did was basically we
added a graphic on top of
the map when Santa cam
mode was active.
And the trick we used here was--
we wanted something that
looked a bit like you were
dreaming or you were looking
through a telescope, or
something a bit magical, fun.
And so we basically got a low
res PNG, semi-transparent with
a kind of transparent border on
the outside, and we simply
scaled it up.
And that worked really,
really well.
So it had a nice
[? alpha value ?]
around it.
And it actually took a fair bit
of time to get the color
right and to get
the [? alpha ?]
[? value ?] right, and
all these things.
It's quite tricky.
ANKUR KOTWAL: I think we should
mention the story of
how the color-- in terms
of getting that right.
We started off with a
fairly dark color.
I think it was black or gray,
but the feedback that we got
was that this might
scare children.
[LAUGHTER]
ANKUR KOTWAL: And so we actually
changed the color
from a dark color to
a yellowy color.
So it was completely see-through
in the middle, and
around the edges, you get a
nice sort of almost a glow
type effect.
So there was one last thing that
I believe we did after
that first internal test,
and that was to make the
experience feel even
more immersive.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
Yeah, we basically
added low profile mode.
So instead of completely going
to full screen and taking over
the entire device, we basically
enabled low profile
mode which dims the task
bar and the buttons.
And the idea was we kind of
trying to draw people into the
app by not completely taking
everything over.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah, that
feedback was really, really
important, and it's something
that we highly recommend
whenever you're building
any software.
Distribute the app to as many
people as you can to get
diverse feedback for it, because
it changed a lot of
our design.
So now let's talk about
the village.
The village was really intended
to be a landing page
for users of the app.
Somewhere where it's the initial
screen that you see,
and it's where users would
be until Santa took off.
So obviously, we had a countdown
to Christmas, until
Santa took off.
The vision behind the Android
app was really to build an
awesome map experience as we
track Santa around the world.
So the village was really
intended to be just somewhere
where users can see the
countdown, and then to have
the interactive elements that
the web version had.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: OK,
it looks pretty good.
that Let's have a look and
talk about some of the
implementation tricks that
you had to go through.
So let's talk about
this image.
That's a huge image you're
using there.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah, so the
village itself was actually
10,000 pixels wide, and what we
did is we split it up into
five slices, because on Android
an image can only be a
maximum of 2048 pixels
either wide or high.
That's the maximum
you can have.
So what we did is we split our
10,000 pixel wide image into
2048 pixel slices, and then
showed it on screen.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: OK.
So as we're watching this scene,
you can see there's
some scrolling happening.
So let's talk about that.
So how are you doing that?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah, we're just
offsetting the images left and
right, But one of things you'll
notice is that the
images in the foreground tend
to scroll at a faster rate
than the images in
the background.
So the village, for example,
scrolls at a faster rate than
the mountains or even
the clouds.
And we've used a technique
that's called parallax
scrolling to achieve that.
What parallax scrolling is
is basically having these
relative speeds for
different layers.
So even though the images--
I said there's five slices.
We actually have different
layers so each layer is split
up into five slices.
So some of the layers we have
are the snow, the village, the
rail for what the monorail sits
on, the mountains and
then the sky.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: OK.
So when you go about
implementing this, did you
have lots of different views
you're putting on top of each
other or how did you
implement that?
ANKUR KOTWAL: No, actually for
something with so many sort of
bits and pieces and so many
graphics, you definitely don't
want to use views, because views
are kind of heavy both
in terms of memory and in terms
of runtime performance.
They're not designed for
something like this.
They're designed for
touch elements.
So what we've done here is
actually used one big view,
which I call the village view,
and I load up a bunch of
images at the start.
And then we override the onDraw
method of the view, and
then just position the different
layers and the
images one on top of each
other and fire them off.
Now the trick is, Android is
going to be called up to 60
times a second, all right,
because the device runs at 60
frames per second.
So the trick is you need to
make sure that you do your
execution within 16
milliseconds, because that's
all the time you have.
So basically what that means
is don't do any memory
allocations or deallocations,
because they will cause a
stutter in your drawing.
You'll blow your 16 millisecond
time limit that
you effectively have and have
a lower performance--
well, lower frame rate.
So you don't want to do that.
And you want to do all your
calculations upfront.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Performance
is a really
interesting point because it
looks very impressive here.
So how well does it work
on a smaller, lower
end, low res device?
Any tricks you had to use?
Any pointers?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah, look,
we definitely
targeted all the devices.
We targeted Android 2.2
or Froyo and up.
And that's, what, three
years old now?
We're talking really lower end,
lower res screens, and
actually they don't have a lot
of memory on them either.
So it's slower CPU, less RAM,
and lower resolution.
So we had assets that we
targeted for each of those
different types of devices, and
we didn't target them to a
specific platform version
or anything.
We actually used the resource
qualifiers that we have in the
resource hierarchy on Android.
So we basically targeted
it at several things.
We looked at things like
the dpi, low dpi,
mdpi, h, and xdpi--
xhdpi.
That obviously got us phone
categorizations, but then you
will say well, what
about tablets?
Because you'll get
some tablets.
I mean, typically, tablets can
perform a lot better than
phones, because they've got
better hardware in them,
typically anyway.
So you'll find something like
the Nexus 7 which is a tvdpi
device, 213dp.
So you want it to have
the high res images.
You don't want the
low res images.
So what we did is we actually
used the resource qualifier
there as well.
So we used sw600dp to identify
it this is a tablet, and we
should target these
resolutions,
these high res images.
And for phones, we just
used the [INAUDIBLE]
xhdpi.
The last thing I want to
say is we didn't do any
specialization in code itself.
We completely used the resource
hierarchy, and that's
really the right way to do it,
because that's what it's
designed for.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
Yeah, thanks.
This looks pretty impressive.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah, I know,
It was a lot of fun.
Great learning exercise.
And really, you should dive
in as developers if you're
exploring graphics.
The Canvas API actually gets you
a long way before you have
to dive into OpenGL, but that's
a separate discussion.
So as we talked about the
village, we said that the map
was really the focus of our
efforts for the Android app.
And up until this point,
we had a fairly vanilla
experience.
I mean you could follow Santa,
and the camera tracked him.
But it was at this point where
we really got our creativity
going and really got excited
about what we could do with
this, and that was using--
like really playing--
by playing with the camera.
So why don't you tell
us a bit about that?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
Yeah, that's right.
So we started adding some more
animations to the camera,
because we can change the zoom
level, we can change the tilt,
we can change the baring,
and all sorts of stuff.
And we just started playing with
it a bit, and I think we
went a bit crazy.
So [? Martin's ?]
idea was to have Santa always
on the screen, but we wanted
to make it really exciting.
So we thought about
like sports news
coverage, for example.
You zoom in.
You can see the whole thing.
You can see what's happening on
the screen, and that's what
we were going for
here, as well.
So we are following
Santa around.
We're zooming in.
We have close-ups of him
going past places.
And then as Santa is getting
closer to a location, his
destination, we actually zoom
in even a bit more, and you
can see exactly where
he is heading.
You can see exactly where
he is going to be next.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah, and as you
can see from the demo here,
we're zooming in, zooming
out, rotating.
At the end of the day, I guess
what we ended up building was
a somewhat cinematic but passive
experience for Santa,
and Santa cam really came
into its own here.
But I also noticed that as these
demos are going and the
rotation's happening,
you can see Santa.
His marker is also rotating.
So obviously, he wasn't
a 3D object.
So how did you go with this?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Yeah, so
markers are always facing one
direction, so there's a
trick you have to use.
So we actually have different
images and just swapping them
and depending on
which direction
Santa's traveling in.
But then the question was-- how
do we know where's Santa
is traveling?
Because you can rotate
the camera.
So we have to calculate where
the direction he's traveling
from, where he's leaving form
his departure to his arrival
location, and we also have to
take into account the camera,
so the direction the camera
is facing at the moment.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah, so we were
basically listening in from a
map view point of view for these
camera update events and
using the on-camera change
listener to tell us that, hey,
the camera is rotated in a
certain way, we now need to
update the marker.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Yeah.
Yeah, that right.
The only trick here was that
you only get these updates
once the camera update
has finished.
So you don't get them as the
camera is animating.
So we are taking an educated
guess to say OK, the camera is
probably going to animate in
this way, so let's swap out
the icons in this direction
and hope that's
going to match up.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Sounds like
you're challenging these
developers, these users
to break it.
But the other thing is I noticed
that you can tap on a
location and bring
up info windows.
Does that all fit well
with all this?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: So
they lost a bit of a
challenge here because--
so you can it's a dashboard at
the bottom giving you some
stats on what Santa
has been up to.
And if you tap on a marker, by
default it always centers it
on the screen.
But if you have the dashboard
open, like on a tablet, the
full expanded version of a
dashboard, it would overlap
the marker.
So we actually had to have a few
extra tricks to make sure
that the marker doesn't
actually overlap the dashboard.
ANKUR KOTWAL: And so we just
basically positioned it--
did an offset so that the
info window was visible.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Exactly.
So basically, calculate how
much space we have on the
screen for the visible map and
basically just put the marker
and then the info window.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah, so that
was the info windows.
We actually tried to make the
dashboard itself fairly
intelligent as well.
So you'll notice that
this map is
implement responsive designed.
So what that means is,
basically, on a phone or on a
tablet, it actually positions
the dashboard
at different locations.
And even its initial state,
whether it's expanded or
summarized, varies depending on
what screens you're using.
So for example, on the phone,
it always starts off in the
collapsed or summary mode as we
called it, whereas on the
tablet, it always starts
off expanded.
But in portrait mode, it will
be in the center of the
screen, whereas in the landscape
mode, it will be at
the bottom right of the screen,
because we just
thought it fit well in terms
of the layout there.
We did make some interesting
decisions there though about
the collapse mode, right?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Yeah, so
we didn't want to lose any
information.
So we basically added--
we're basically scrolling in the
extra information from the
bottom of the dashboard.
So you're not going to
miss out on anything.
And we also added a marquee
effect to it.
So if you have text coming in
that too long, it doesn't fit
into the one line.
This is basically scrolling
it through.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah, and
that's particularly
important when we localize.
Remember that, because of this
text can be a lot longer.
So, yeah, that's
the dashboard.
So at this point in the
development life cycle, we
were looking pretty good.
The app was coming together.
It was looking fairly
complete.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: But
I think there was still
something missing.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Sound effects!
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
And presents.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yes, of course.
So with sound effects,
we started adding--
up until this point, the
app was a silent app.
Which it was still fun, but as
soon as we started adding
sound effects--
we added some birds in the
village, some jingles for the
sleigh, and even Santa himself
would chuck in a "ho ho ho"
every so often, and it just
really livened up the
experience.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Yeah, yeah,
it really did, and the
presents were quite good, too.
I mean that's why Santa
is traveling
around the world, right?
So our Santa is also giving
out presents.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So how did you
implement the presents then?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: So each of
his presents-- as you can
see here, they're moving
over the map--
they're actually markers.
So we're basically animating
markers again.
But as you can see, the presents
are dropping on to
the ground.
So we actually have different
markers that
we're swapping in.
So we have icons we're using.
They're a bit more transparent
with the
presents a bit smaller.
We're basically swapping those
in, looks like the presents is
falling on to the ground.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Well, into
people's houses and not onto
people, right?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
Yeah, that's right.
Let's hope so.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah, so now
we have an animated Santa
delivering presents, traveling
around the world.
You know, at this point we had
a real sense of satisfaction
that this app was kind of fun.
We hoped that families
all around the
world would enjoy it.
So I guess this really concludes
today's Google
Developer Live.
We hope that those of you that
use the app enjoyed it as much
as we enjoyed building it, and
I guess we'll see you next
time
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
Yeah, see you.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Bye bye.
[HO HO HO]
[SLEIGHT BELLS]